this is where this is the kind of cruise
the crucial you know
uh kind of almost binary
difference which
which produces an immense amount of
psychological benefit
the moment you can really notice
thoughts themselves as appearances in
consciousness rather than
what you are in each moment because what
happens is in the default case
the thoughts kind of creep up from
behind us in some sense they kind of
come out of nowhere
and that just feels like me right so i'm
you know i'm trying to
it's a reflexive identification yeah you
wouldn't act the damn things out if they
didn't feel like you you know and so
they have to have that impulse to action
in them that that's part of felt
identity right so you're saying that
you're saying and this is part of i
suppose part of the buddhist tradition
particularly although not only that
being the the puppet of those thoughts
is part of what prolongs suffering at
least under some circuits especially
being the puppet of them yes
okay yeah so and so this is so but the
the people you know listening to us now
can feel this so you know that you know
we're talking and people are trying to
understand the threat of this
conversation but it's comp they have a
voice in their head that's competing
with this right they you know they're
trying to listen to us
but they're also thinking right and i
think so they might think
what the hell's he talking about right
like there's just some some intrusive
thought comes in or like oh no wait a
minute he didn't answer the question
that
thought that that feels if you're
identified with it if you don't see it
as mere language
appearing in consciousness
or mere imagery right
it feels like me it's like that is the
self that isn't it doesn't feel like
what i believe yeah it's just that
that's no space
yeah well one of the things you do in
clinical work all the time
especially in the cognitive behavioral
field is you help people
identify those thoughts in some sense as
as objects
to no longer identify with them and to
say you know just because you think that
it's not necessarily true it's not
necessarily you and it's not necessarily
helpful and it is it does have this
dreamlike character of
both
coming out of nowhere and seizing
completely seizing the reins of of
attention and identity and taking us
elsewhere
um
and
also we forget it we it has a that's
part of the totalitarian spirit of
rationality that proclivity
well but it is but a lot of these
thoughts aren't rational it's just it's
just you're just rehearsing your
experience it's just like you'll tell
yourself the same thing 10 times in a
row and never and you won't be bored on
the 10th time you'll you'll like if you
just imagine
what it would be like to externalize
your thoughts on a loudspeaker for
everyone to listen to
you know and you were just you just it
was just
helplessly you know externalized
every every normal person would sound
insane
you know because it because of the the
perseveration
and the
and just the redundancy and the
and the strange structure to
the discursiveness i mean this is this
is a um
you know this is ever present it's so
it's so ever present that it strike it
doesn't strike people as strange but
to be presuming we have a we have a
dialogue with ourselves as though the
eye could talk to the me
and that made any sense at all it's like
you know i'm sitting here
and you're getting set up for this
interview right and
i i'll think
um oh i got to get some water right
now
i know
if i'm the one to say it
and i'm the one here
i know i need water who am i telling you
it's like it's like i'm telling someone
else um a big habit that i'm working on
which is going to be really hard to
explain
in any way that any normal human being
will understand this but i'm trying to
turn off my monkey mind
uh
like i think we are when we're born as
children we're pretty blank slates we're
living very much in the moment
uh and we're essentially just reacting
to our environment through our instincts
uh and we're living in what i would call
the real world uh and then when puberty
comes along it's the onset of desire
it's the first time you really really
want something
and you start long-range planning for it
and then because of that you start
thinking a lot and you start building an
identity and ego to go and get what you
want and this is all normal and healthy
it's part of being the human animal
but i think at some point it gets out of
control uh and then we are constantly
just talking to ourselves in our heads
we're playing little movies in our heads
walking down the street but no one's
actually there now of course you started
voicing this thought in your head that
you're always having you'd be a madman
and they'd lock you up but the reality
is if you walk down the street there's a
thousand people in the street i think
all thousands are talking to themselves
in their head at any given point they're
constantly judging everything that they
see they're playing back movies of
things that happened to them yesterday
they're living in fantasy worlds of
what's going to happen tomorrow
and they're just pulled out of base
reality uh and that can be good when
you're doing long-range planning it can
be good when you're solving problems
it's good for the survival and
replication machines that we are but i
think it's actually very bad for your
happiness um and so
uh in my mind the the mind should be a
servant or tool my master it's not
something that should be controlling me
and driving me 24 7.
so i've taken on this idea that
i want to break the habit of
uncontrolled thinking
which is hard because if i say to you
don't think of a pink elephant i just
put a pink elephant in your head
so it's it's it's an almost impossible
problem so it's more something that has
to be guided by feel
uh than guided by actual thinking or
thought process
but i'm deliberately cultivating
experiences
states of mind locations activities
that will help me get out of my mind
and i know you know all of society does
that to some extent in some sense the
the
people chasing thrills and action sports
or flow states or
orgasms or any of these states that
people really strive to get to a lot of
these are basically just trying to get
out of your own head they're trying to
get away from that voice in your head
and this over developed sense of self at
the very least i do not want my sense of
self to continue to develop and become
stronger as i get older i want it to be
weaker and more muted
so that i can live much more in present
everyday reality and accept nature and
the world for what it is
and appreciate it very much as a child
would
and then not have to seek
happiness through external circumstances
chasing to fit some preconceived notion
that i have
wow there's a lot there i want to ask
questions on is there yeah that's a
tough one that'll take years that's
that's not a six month habit that's a
10-year habit do you think there's a
difference between turning off or
versus uh suppressing your monkey mind
absolutely yeah suppression doesn't work
because when you try to suppress that's
the mind suppressing the mind that's
just you playing games with yourself
so i think it's i think it's a very hard
problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you